because our friend Sam Harris coined an
interesting word this week a phrase
regressive leftists you know the people
who don't quite get it
about being liberals in the world I know
you were championing somebody named
Merriam namazi and you and my great
friend Salman Rushdie got her reinstated
she was going to speak as so many people
have at universities and then they get
disinvited because she's an ex-muslim
and was just speaking her mind but
apparently that's hate speech in this
world so what did you and I am and
rocked about the way at on university
campuses the principle of free speech
when I think that the only diversity I
went to University of California at
Berkeley the free speech movement in the
1960s what a betrayal we're seeing now
right with campuses all over the Western
model America and Britain are denying
people the right to come and speak at
campuses if you can't speak your mind on
a university campus where can you I mean
that's what universities are about it's
about free speech it's about being
it's it's about being exposed to ideas
that you you haven't met before perhaps
you're hostile to if you only ever get
exposed to ideas that you agree with
what kind of a university would that be
but also there's this notion that that
somehow Islam and Muslims are this
protected species that if we talk about
them at all or criticize at all it's
somehow hurting or humiliating Muslims
yes and if that's a ridiculous it's
confused with racism as well because of
incredible number of people think Islam
is a race yes oh I've heard that yeah
bro and so they think that if you
criticize Islam you're being you're
being racist right or um and you're
absolutely right that the regressive
Muslims give a free pass to Islam where
they they kind of write about everything
else I mean they're right about misogyny
and and all the other other good things
bad things in that case um I my
repressive leftist yeah liberals yes yes
but in the case of Islam it just gets a
free pass yeah and I think it's because
of the terror of being thought racist
right or or in it or at worst in
Islamophobe I'm a phobia yes a silly
word that means nothing
yes I mean it's it's so dumb because you
know all the people who are accused of
being Islamophobes like you and me and
Sam and ayaan we're liberals were
liberals about everything we're working
yeah I was I mean from the time I was a
child in my home I was seven years old
when my parents told me were for Kennedy
and him trying to let black people go to
college in the South I didn't even know
who black people were there weren't any
in my town I knew we were on their side
and then we were on the side of Cesar
Chavez and the lettuce Pickers and then
we were on the side and we're on the
side of the women's movement and poor
and the minorities that whatever was gay
people had the disabled the abused the
molested whatever Caitlyn is up to we
were for it
and they applaud that and if you say
something about a woman who's forced to
wear a beekeeper suit in the hot Sun all
day oh that's their culture you have to
respect it that's right that's what they
say it's just enjoy is just a one
exception liber about everything else
but then lose this one exception it's
their culture well to hell with their
culture there you go dr. Richard Dawkins
you